a horrible Pig if I say you have pretty
eyes I don't mean I'll be like
second-story I'm sorry so everyone seen
the famous New York cat calling video
lots of reactions now granted some of
those cat calls were inappropriate and
should not be tolerated but some of them
that's an inappropriate cat call now hey
you have a good day miss and here's the
thing she said that this footage was
taken over 10 hours with a hundred cat
calls in New York that made the
highlight reel she was scraping the
bottom of the barrel with have a nice
day miss what do you think the other 80
something cat calls worth it's a
compliment
hey but is this representative of all
women even most women even a tiny sliver
of women
I took a hidden camera to the local mall
to find out gorgeous hair look bright
red oh you have a beautiful smile I love
your hair I like your glasses
we have very pretty eyes how's your
birthday December I mean the perfect
stone for your eyes even worse than have
a nice day miss I actually complimented
them on their features that one woman
was offended or mad as a matter of fact
when I apologized and with that a
non-creepy way it's beautiful thank you
great thanks sorry did you I'm sorry I
shouldn't have said that bad I didn't
mean to be inappropriate I spent it's
pretty hair okay okay sorry I shouldn't
I I meant that in a complimentary way
neither creepy way I know it's okay good
thank you my apologies
but I don't mean that in the connection
I'm in a creepy way I mean in a
complimentary way
fine are you oh you have pretty eyes
they didn't paint it in a way that was
sexist or chauvinistic yeah I mean
there's a compliment sorry not as I
don't mean it'll be like sex okay I'm a
horrible Pig if I say you have pretty
eyes now okay okay there you go right
well okay good thing it made her day you
know how much it made her day she then
started rubbing lotion on my hands I
felt like I was being sexually exploited
so what does this prove to us at the end
of the day
not a ton namely that anyone can edit
and make a youtube video also that
feminists suck